and meantime back here at home guns and
roses putting on a show tonight over at
allegiant stadium here is a look at some
of the traffic cams in the area folks
slowly starting to make their way out to
the stadium for that big show if you're
wondering where brian loftus is well you
got one guess
he's there arko mana joining us now live
from allegiant with a look at the
parking and also what you're not allowed
to bring into the venue orco so many
people are surprised at the last minute
of what they can and cannot bring
that's right denise well here at
allegiant stadium we are here waiting
for that guns and roses concert to start
the doors here actually just open and
the parking lots around the venue opened
about an hour ago and then i want to
show you this over here we're already
seeing a large number of the cones and
the traffic personnel around to make
sure that all those fans coming here
are
able to get here without any issues and
you'll remember there were issues during
the garth brooks concert and the gold
cup final and here are some parking
reminders for you if you're heading out
here on site at allegiant there are lots
a through j you can also park at certain
mgm properties such as mandalay bay and
luxor and for those looking to avoid
parking the rideshare drop-off zone is
in lot n on dean martin a short walking
distance to the stadium and here's a
look at allegiance bag policy as denise
was alluding to earlier approved bags
include 12 by 6 by 12 clear backpacks
clear fanny packs and one gallon
plastic freezer bags and small clutches
but you will not be able to bring in
regular backpacks purses or oversized
tote bags as well as these other items
that you see on your screen so for
example if you have a bag like this
you're going to be asked to leave and
bring it to your car but you can also
use the venue's bag check but that'll
cost you about twenty dollars again guns
and roses here to legion stadium the
event starting at seven o'clock tonight
reporting live at allegiant stadium orca
mana 8 news now